I shared with you my artimistic protocol. I am starting in a few days. I also read it by my local functional doctor and she has many unartimisticated for many things.
I was just wondering if you had any comments or things to add.
I know there was someone else on here that had bone metastatic issues. I still have not heard back from the oncologist so no reason to wait any longer.
I paid as high level of times in managing. So again, like we shared last week or the week before, I think artimisticated is great.
And there's no harm in adding it to your protocol. It has been shown that effect. I think I just updated a blog post on artimisticated with some new information.
So look at that blog post. I think I don't think there's really any harm in taking artimisticated unless a person is just taking way too many.
So that would be my only concern is that if a person just taking way too much stuff, then maybe artimisticated is not best to add to your protocol.
But yeah, go for it. I think it's a great addition.
Artimisticated is not going to be really, you know, you said your paid isn't high level. Artimisticated is really a pain decrease or no.
Maybe think of some of the other things that I talked about and the other question about helping pay.